What will happen to this file now?
Tip of the Iceberg
Destroying Evidence
In front of the cameras,
an Israeli bullet assassinates our colleague,
Shireen Abu Akleh,
through which the occupation
sought to assassinate the image
and kill the truth
However, this crime
managed to revive dozens of files
of journalists who were killed
on Palestinian land
whose names and the moments
when assassinated
remained sculpted in people's minds
Despite that, their lawsuits
are still pursuing unfound justice.
Ready!
Quickly!
CALL THE AMBULANCE!
AMBULANCE!
Come Here!
Stay there!
Stay with her!
These terrifying snaps
documented the assassination of our colleague,
Shireen Abu Akleh,
before the whole world
On 11 May 2022,
here in Jenin, Shireen was martyred
with a bullet from an Israeli soldier
that targeted her directly
and our colleague, Ali Al-Samoudi,
was also shot
while accompanying her
to accomplish a journalistic mission.
There is no god but Allah!
One year has passed
since the assassination,
and the Israeli occupation
is still vigorously trying
to avoid responsibility and pay the price
The FBI took over
the investigation into Shireen's case,
as she held American nationality.
According to the information we got,
a team of the FBI
investigated Shireen's case on the ground,
away from the media,
in cooperation with
the Palestinian Public Prosecutor's Office
American experts also analyzed
video and audio clips
of the assassination incident
In this investigation,
we managed to interview Steven Beck
the investigator and expert
who previously cooperated
with the American
Bureau of Investigation FBI
The man undertook
an in-depth audio analysis task
of the widely spread video clips
on Shireen Abu Akleh's assassination
I have analyzed tens of thousands
of fire-shooting clips,
so I have a good idea of
what I'm looking for.
First of all,
you start watching the video and listening
to the audio simultaneously
Anyone injured?
Ambulance!
Mujahed!
I've been shot!
Shireen! Oh man!
Shireen!
But you couldn't see
where the bullets were coming from
You couldn't see anyone shooting
At that point,
I had to depend on the audio,
and something else that drew my attention
was the surrounding.
So, I noticed that
there was a group of journalists
who were walking down the street
In that street,
there were walls and houses too
So that was restraining the bullets' course
Therefore, the audio contained much additional
information that was unavailable in the video
So when the shooting started
and the bullet caused a shock,
after that, the muzzle blasted
There was a time difference
From the time difference,
I could calculate
and estimate how far the shooter was
According to my calculations,
the shooter was
at a distance between 180 to 201 metres
We also discovered
that there was a group of
Israeli Defense soldiers
around 200 metres
away from that intersection
where the journalist and the person
recording with the cell phone were
So, the sound signature
matches the distance
And those bullets were directed
towards the journalist.
So, I firmly believe that
this supports the fact that
the shots came from
the Israeli Defence (IDF) soldiers
Were they targeting the journalists?
They were definitely
aiming at the journalists
To London,
the capital of the United Kingdom
We went to meet a person
who experienced Israel's policies
and practices in the file
of targeting journalists
Detective Chris Cobb-Smith,
a former British Officer
He investigated the killing of journalists
by the Israeli occupation army
and was informed of the details of colleague
Shireen Abu Akleh's assassination
First and foremost, the shot
that hit Shireen was not a random fire
Although those shots were inconsistent,
they were intentional
Some of the shots hit the tree
close to where she was standing
Those were not random shots
How do you view the outcome of the
Israeli handling of Shireen's case?
Will they repeat the way they dealt
with the killing of other journalists
in addition to destroying evidence
and escaping from accountability?
Yes. In fact, there was a
complete explanation
in the investigation and an
admission of responsibility
by the Israeli army
and the Israeli authorities
They started to provide excuses
directly after the incident
If you look in detail
at the people's locations
and military units;
where the journalists were standing;
the distances,
and the footage filmed at that time,
then one of them will be blamed
for that incident
Once again,
I'm not sure the person responsible
will be held accountable
One of the most prominent cases
that Smith investigated
was the case of British journalist
James Miller in 2003,
who was shot by an Israeli soldier
in the city of Rafah
in the southern Gaza Strip
Smith's investigation
was at the official request of the Miller family
and the institution he worked for
and with the British government's support
The investigation documents in
the Miller case, which we reviewed,
revealed the extent of Israeli manipulation
and reflected a systematic policy
of targeting journalists
and evading punishment
Like other cases
in which journalists were targeted
However, what is striking
in the James Miller case,
according to Detective Smith,
is a mistake made by the Israeli army
in one of the investigations documents
provided to the family and their lawyer
The error revealed an aspect the Israeli
military was keen to hide in the case
We know that the Israeli army
always deliberately
conceals the names
of the soldiers or officers
directly responsible
for involvement in the killings
and assassinations of journalists
In James Miller's case, it was noted
that the officer's name
was leaked,
maybe by mistake, as you mentioned
A document published
by the Israeli authorities
obscures all the individuals involved
Still, there was
one name that was not hidden;
a lieutenant
in the Israel Defense Forces
- Officer?
- An Officer, that's correct
Do you think that showing the name
was by mistake?
I believe it was by mistake
because it had been concealed
It has been deleted from the entire report
Yet, it appeared in one line only;
therefore, we know who that officer is
This is the document where
the Israeli officer's name was shown
while it has been referred to
in the other documents with the code H
After revealing the name of the Israeli officer
in addition to the British government's pressure on the case,
correspondence that we viewed revealed
a settlement offer made
by the Israeli Ministry of Defense
through the British Embassy in Tel Aviv
in December 2005
to close the file
In 2008,
a settlement was announced
under which Israel paid
financial compensation for one million
and 750 thousand pounds sterling
to the family of James Miller
in exchange for closing the file of the trial
of any Israeli soldier in the case
Without this political pressure
from the British government,
do you expect
things would not have reached
compensation and this outcome?
As you know,
I do not doubt that the pressure
from the British government
significantly impacted
the Israeli authorities' response
So, when it comes to
local Palestinian journalists,
there is no such political pressure
and hence rights are lost
It would seem so,
unfortunately
While the family of the
British journalist received
financial compensation supported
by the British government,
the cases of local Palestinian journalists
piled up
without justice
or any attempt at compensation
One of the most prominent
is the case of Palestinian journalist
Fadel Shana,
the British Agency
Reuters' Cameraman in Gaza
In 2008,
he was targeted directly
by an Israeli tank shell
while doing his journalistic work
in the middle of the Gaza Strip
Fifteen years have passed
since the incident,
without any accountability
or legal condemnation,
it seemed as if the file
on his assassination had been closed
Reuters sent a British team
to investigate this file with lawyers
but to no avail
It was useless as this team
did not fulfil its investigations
They fulfilled their investigations in
Gaza Strip with us as a family, a team, a place
They inspected the location
But they firmly refused
to deal with the Israelis
As a family, we are following
the course of the case,
Reuters assures us that
they will follow up on the file
when the conscience
of the soldier or officer
who gave the order to kill Fadel, wakes up
We are still waiting for the conscience
of the Israeli soldiers to confess to killing Fadel
deliberately and targeting Fadel personally
This place is a witness to the killing of journalist
Fadel Shana by an Israeli tank shell,
which led to his death along with other
young men and children who were near him
One of those
who witnessed these bloody moments
is the photojournalist Muhammad Al-Baba
We arrived here;
this was the last point we could reach
because the Israeli tank was in that area
So, therefore, we were unable
to reach the event area
It means we did not get to the mosque
where the incident occurred
So, he got out of his car
and set up his tripod
It was like Fadel
to pay attention to everything
related to security or occupational safety
He had a small press Jeep
with the word "PRESS" on it,
and he was standing right next to it
I remember standing 10 metres away from him
and seeing him in front of me
We were filming straight
in that direction
And I remember in those days
that these buildings did not yet exist
It was an empty area, and that was the place
where the Israeli tank was positioned
We started filming, and Fadel was there,
ready with his camera
We were also there,
pointing our cameras in that direction
It wasn't a long distance
to presume that the tank did not see us
On the contrary,
the tank could see us clearly
We wore special clothes like jackets etc
We also wore helmets on our heads
that had "PRESS" written on them
Thus, we were visible to the Israeli tank
Suddenly, while we were filming,
heavy gunfire started
They assassinated Fadel
They wanted him dead
From a distance of 10 metres,
I took two pictures focusing on Fadel
I stood by Fadel and found his blood spilt
and his neck severed
And I started screaming Fadel, Fadel...
Because this was
one of the harrowing scenes,
to see my colleague soaked in blood
and slaughtered
It was a painful scene
I remember stopping filming,
My entire body was shaking,
and I started screaming,
and I couldn't control my nerves
or camera anymore
The Israeli army announced
shortly after the assassinations
of Fadel Shana,
a clear and complete vindication of
the tank crew from the assassination charge
The Israeli army lawyer said
that it was not clear to the soldiers
whether Fadel was carrying
a camera or a gun
and that the jacket he was wearing
was similar to the jackets worn by
Palestinian terrorists, as they claim
The lawyer concluded that
the tank crew acted appropriately
and they would not face
any legal action accordingly
This targeting is done
clearly and publicly,
with crude and unacceptable justifications
that can be refuted
Sometimes they say
the camera looked like an RPG;
they were in the wrong place
at the wrong moment;
it was an unintentional target,
and another target
should have been targeted
They always find excuses
In this investigation,
we contacted Reuters News Agency,
seeking to conduct an interview
and inquire about the latest developments in
the case of its journalist, Fadel Shana
Its officials refused to be interviewed
and sent a written response,
“Everyone who handled this situation has moved on…”
In his message,
a spokesman for the agency expressed
deep sorrow for Fadel's loss
and emphasised protecting
the rights of journalists
wherever they are in their coverage
Reuters was in charge of all these matters
and followed them up with specialists
from institutions to protect journalists
Institutions
to follow up on the files
of the killing of journalists
Still,
Reuters
did not inform us of anything
because Palestinian journalists
are numbers
for international and universal
news agencies and channels
They cannot fight,
or they cannot
give, or confront Israel
because of existing and shared interests
In the documents we looked at
in this investigation,
it was remarkable that
the Israeli Military Advocate General
used the term military activity
to describe what the soldiers were doing
when the journalists were targeted
The Israeli occupation army
relied upon a pretext
to justify targeting
journalists and civilians
and exempting its officers and soldiers
from any legal responsibility
It considers that whoever is present in
the location of combat operations,
and this, of course,
is a very loose and broad term
used limitlessly
by being in these places
and being exposed to harm,
whether by gunfire,
rubber bullets, injured or killed
They consider that the state
is exempt from any responsibility
towards this person
because he is in an area
of a combative nature.
The Palestinian journalist Moath Amarneh
lost an eye by an Israeli sniper's bullet
that hit him
while covering a peaceful sit-in
against settler attacks in November 2019
in Surif,
north of Hebron, in the West Bank
And I was standing here,
visible to the army
I was 100% visible
The camera is with me
Something hit me
I didn't know what it was
I felt at that time
that my head had taken off
I started shouting, "I'm injured"
Journalists came around
and tried to give me first aid
At this time, the army came upon us
One of them was carrying a camera
and filming
He came to document this injury
Since that time,
Amarneh has not succeeded
in moving forward with any legal action
against the occupation soldiers
before the Israeli judiciary
We went to file a lawsuit,
but we stopped and did not continue
because the police dealt with the matter,
and their response was so negative
that they did not even hear
any statement from me
Their response was that the injury was in
a site of operations
or a military area
in a state of war,
and the casualties in these areas
they do not deal with
We tried more than once, but
their handling of the issue stopped us
Because what we will do
at that time is what we call
"shaking water"
Meaning that no soldier
would be held accountable
and the case
would not be dealt with as required,
so we did not continue
Unfortunately, the IDF seems,
in such situations,
seems to feel that
they can get away with anything
Not only the James Miller incident,
which I thoroughly investigated
and spent a lot of time working on
I was involved in investigating
Tom Hurndall's shooting
and Rachel Corey's death
These incidents do not appear
to be taken seriously
It also seems the soldiers are confident
they can get away with it
because whatever they do,
their actions will be covered up,
which is unacceptable
It is unacceptable
that they claim to be
one of the most powerful militaries
in the world
Statistics indicate that 55 journalists
have been killed since 2000
by Israeli occupation bullets
in the West Bank and Gaza Strip
Yasser Murtaja,
another Palestinian journalist,
was killed by an Israeli sniper's bullet
that targeted him
while covering the return marches
at the Gaza Strip border in 2018
Israel adopted the same legal argument,
considering Murtaja's presence
in a military zone
Allah is the Greatest
The Israeli Defense Minister at the time,
Avigdor Lieberman,
accused Murtaja, the journalist,
of flying a filming drone
over the occupation soldiers
The response to Lieberman's accusations
came from the US State Department,
which defended US funding
for the media company
founded by Yasser Murtaja in Gaza
by saying
that Murtaja had been vetted under
U.S. government guidelines
Despite the refutation
of the Israeli story,
the Israeli occupation army has not
condemned any of its soldiers
until today
We tried to find out
about the soldier who killed Yasser
by filing a lawsuit
through the Israeli court,
but the Israeli court did not respond
It declined to respond to this issue,
it was not clear who was
the person who killed Yasser
or who gave the order to kill Yasser
We found that
the Israeli occupation authorities
enacted this law
and not only enacted the law
but also enacted another law
that forbids revealing the identity
of any of the soldiers who fought
or the Israeli forces who shot
or caused damage
or who killed Palestinians
Thus, it committed two violations
of Palestinian rights:
First, it absolved itself
of responsibility as a state,
as a system, and as an entity
Secondly, it covered up
the soldier or the security officer
who shot fire
While exploring the Israeli documents,
we find that Israel
has amended its military policies
with the second intifada
that broke out in 2000
Accordingly,
army soldiers and officers
are exempted from accountability
in case of what it calls
"military activity"
The most dangerous of all
is that the Public Prosecutor's Office
has never investigated
a case as the investigation should be,
meaning that there is, for example, a crime
that occurred,
as it was done against the martyr Murtaja
The press jacket was visible on him,
and the PRESS word
the camera in his hand
They could see him clearly,
yet he was targeted by a sniper
and killed
they do not investigate
this matter
but instead investigate
whether Israel is at war or not
Is Israel in a state of conflict or not?
Therefore, simply opening an investigation
in the presence of a war crime
does not occur
Thus, the Military Prosecutor
is working to cover up
this crime
and give it legal cover from the beginning
The area where we were filming,
as you can see,
was only about 50 metres
away from Salah al-Din
Salah al-Din is the mainline
for the Gaza Strip,
so we are in a civilian area
and a populated place
I remember there were people here watching,
and there were children
too
Pupils were on their way home from school
We didn't hear any gunfire
We didn't hear…
I mean, we didn't hear gunfire
from another side
We didn't hear things
that caught our attention
that made us
at least take heed
The shooting that took place
and led to deaths and injuries
simultaneously,
I do not think that it is from
the capabilities of the Gaza Strip,
but it was the enormous tank here
The killing of journalist Yasser Murtaja
was utterly premeditated
He was wearing protective armour,
and as you know,
it covers the belly area until here,
and then it is all
visible from the top,
in addition to the helmet
So now you are talking about a bullet
from a professional sniper,
not any person
to say that
the shot was random
The bullet hit directly
from under the armour
and penetrated Yasser's abdomen
Israel classifies the Gaza Strip
as a hostile zone,
exposing everyone in it
as a military target
The Israeli judiciary shields
behind this argument
for not summoning witnesses
and hearing their statements
in the cases of journalists
who died in Gaza
Everyone from the Gaza Strip
since 2001
cannot go to
the Israeli military courts,
and the Israeli judicial system
has prevented the submission
of these complaints
when it considered
the Gaza Strip as hostile territory
Unfortunately, the Israeli judiciary
forms along with the general prosecution
the political and legal cover
for the war crimes
and crimes against humanity
committed by the occupation,
including journalists
Both local and international
In the West Bank,
the pretexts and excuses
for killing journalists have changed,
but the result is the same
Another Palestinian journalist
killed in front of the cameras
Nazih Darwazeh
He was killed by an Israeli soldier
during his field coverage
in the city of Nablus in the West Bank
Today, after 20 years,
his legal file has been closed,
and its documents have disappeared
from the Israeli courts
We interviewed his son, Sameh,
who was a child
when his father was martyred,
and today he is striving
to access his father's file
in the Israeli courts,
as he reveals being subjected
to financial blackmail,
as he described it,
to obtain the file
Sameh, it is very difficult, difficult,
you must do something
I started working on the file,
and by God, seriously, I started
I am working on it
and I want to win the case
and I will do the impossible for it
I am working on it, analysing,
and submitting requests,
and there are many other requests
that we must submit
so that we can file the case properly
Because what they did to you was not fair
Now you must do what needs to be done
Sameh, do what needs to be done,
I do not care
Until Sunday you have to arrange
a sum of money
You have to get the money ready first
to proceed
you can divide them into two instalments
I want 5000 Jordanian dinars
These papers are tightly secured
and I know how to get them out, okay?
Now I want to tell you something
if you want because
I want to go on
and I tell you that I will continue
and I will not stop
because I really want these files
Now
You are now obliged to pay me
No documents were sent to us
by the investigation party
or any other party
We tried to look at the papers
in court
Still, so far,
we have not been able to obtain
either the investigation,
the files inside the court,
or the soldier's testimony
if his testimony has already been taken
Or the force that stormed in that period
Sometime after my father's martyrdom,
my mother personally
appointed a lawyer
from the Arab citizens of Israel,
and this lawyer
took her signature on papers
written in Hebrew,
the power of attorney and other stuff
until approximately
5-6 years passed
since he was appointed,
The witnesses
whose names are known
as we gave him their names
and contacted the witnesses,
none of the witnesses
received a request to attend
The lawyer had informed the court
that the witnesses could not attend
because they were missing
for security reasons,
meaning they could not obtain permits
We were standing here,
and this was just the space
we were hiding in
We hide from the bullets of the occupation
Nazih was here,
and I was next to him
My shoulder was next to his shoulder
This was the only space,
and when the shooting happens,
we go back inside the house
to protect ourselves a bit
But eventually, you have to go out
to take pictures
I heard from his family
and people about the court,
but I was not summoned
and was not asked to attend,
even though I was close to him
shoulder to shoulder
I was the best to speak on this subject,
but I was not summoned,
and no testimony was taken from me
Although I was demanding
and speaking to the media
that an investigation was necessary
and that I was ready
I am also fluent in Hebrew and English,
and I am ready to speak all languages,
but no one contacted me,
and no one came to inquire
about what happened
I wish I had been summoned
but if they didn't give me a permit
I wouldn't be able to go
It would be the same outcome
So, if one of the colleagues were summoned
and did not go
because he did not obtain a permit,
the result would have been the same
Even if I was summoned
yet banned from going
it would be the same idea
Whether any colleague
was contacted to attend,
or wasn't,
all is the same
because everyone will not reach
the court
I wished to reach the court and speak
fluently about what happened because I am an eyewitness
I was right next to Nazih Darwazeh
when he was targeted and killed
in cold blood,
but this is what happened
We contacted the American Associated Press
to inquire about developments
in the case of Nazih Darwazeh,
who was a cameraman for the agency
However, despite many correspondences
and attempts,
we did not receive any response from them
until the date of
broadcasting this investigation
In fact,
the AP agency
visited us
after the assassination
and attended the funeral,
but the problem is that
they did not take any legal action
They did not follow up on any file
legally,
although it is a well-known agency
and is supposed to take it upon itself
to research this issue
No legal effort
was made in this matter
and the case was not pursued,
neither in Israeli courts
nor in international courts
I think that the AP
is an American agency,
so it is possible
that they have…
They did not follow up on this matter
because it is possible
since they are based in America,
this may pose
a problem for them
in their work
This document issued
by the Israeli court in Haifa
related to the case
of the assassination of journalist
Nazih Darwazeh
reveals that the closure of the case
resulted from the witnesses
not appearing before the court
This pretext
was repeated in more than one case,
given the deliberate prevention
of witnesses
from accessing the courts
by the Israeli authorities
I remember that the witnesses
who were present
and whose names we have submitted
did not attend any hearings
and were not even notified of
the dates of the hearings
to attend
None of our testimonies was heard
in court because initially,
we were not informed
of any session or any date,
meaning that
we felt that there was collusion
between the court
and the assigned lawyer
Because, actually
I learned in those days, from the lawyer
that an internal investigation
had been carried out in the army
And that investigation
resulted in
concealing the name of the soldier
who carried out the assassination,
and then
the information disappeared utterly
The occupation does not want
to prosecute any soldier,
whether in the past, present or future
The occupying state
the most significant thing it can do
even if convicted is paying money
Many cases have ended in compensation
They say we are not
prosecuting our soldiers
Our soldiers were at war
And I heard this matter in court,
as I was present in other sessions
that this is war
You are present in this war
and satisfied for yourself what will be
You came to battle
As a journalist,
you bear your responsibility
and are part of this war
If you die, we are not responsible
Suppose the party
conducting the investigation
is affiliated with
the Israeli army,
one of the arms of the Israeli military
In that case, it will naturally
investigate the file
in a way
that protects
its story
Even if we go to
the judicial system,
assuming the Israeli judicial system
The Israeli judicial system
deals with the same mentality
It is shameful and humiliating
for any judicial body
to constitute
a legal framework
for war crimes
and crimes against humanity,
mainly if it targets
civilians
and specifically if
it targets freedom of opinion
and expression
In front of all this
evidence and accusations
against the Israeli occupation,
we sent a letter to the Israeli army
to ask about the issues of journalists
raised in this investigation
and the allegations levelled against it
of destroying evidence,
covering up the killer soldiers
and facilitating their impunity
We received a lengthy response from
the spokesperson of the occupation army
He avoided mentioning
any of the names of the victim journalists
and the details of their files
He repeatedly elaborated
on the security pretexts
and talked about activities
of a combative nature,
as he described,
in the places where the victims fall,
including journalists
Israel's systematic policy of denial
and evasion of accountability
and responsibility
was apparent in cases
of targeting journalists,
the latest of which was the case of
colleague Shireen Abu Akleh
According to private sources,
a senior Israeli official
in the office of former Defense Minister
Benny Gantz
admitted to US officials
that Shireen
was killed by gunfire fired
by Israeli soldiers by mistake
Still, Israel
will not announce it
or officially recognize it
In light of an international campaign
condemning the assassination of Shireen Abu Akleh,
Al Jazeera Media Network
filed a case with the
International Criminal Court in The Hague
Al Jazeera announced
that this step
came after its legal team
conducted an investigation
that revealed new evidence
that clearly showed
that Shireen and her colleagues
were exposed to direct gunfire
by the Israeli occupation army
And the claim by the Israeli authorities
that they mistakenly killed Shireen
during an exchange of fire
is baseless.
Concurrently,
the Palestinian Journalists Syndicate,
in cooperation with the
International Federation of Journalists,
filed a complaint with the Office of the
Attorney General of the International Criminal Court
In addition to Shireen Abu Akleh's file,
the complaint included
the two files of the assassination of
journalists Yasser Murtaja
and Ahmed Abu Hussein in Gaza
And also the two files
of the injuries of the two journalists,
Moath Amarneh
and Nidal Shtayyeh in the West Bank
Exactly on September 20,
we submitted the file to the
International Criminal Court
We were subjected to logistical harassment,
but ultimately,
the International Federation
and we handed over the file
So we had an international
cover and umbrella
for our international movement
We handed over this file,
and Tony Abu Akleh, the brother of
the martyr Shireen, was with us
Al-Jazeera was thankful
that it covered
the matter
On September 6, we received a letter
that I will give to you
It includes what it means
to have started the procedures,
but we consider that insufficient
This is the response that the
Palestinian Journalists Syndicate received
from the International Criminal Court
after submitting the complaint,
informing it of receiving the application
and proceeding to review it
Remarkably,
the approach to the
International Criminal Court
was limited to cases targeting journalists
that occurred after 2014
This raised several questions
about the fate of the targeting of
journalists in the preceding years
A clear and explicit statement
in the Rome Charter
of the International Criminal Court
states in
a simple, clear,
and categoric that
the International Criminal Court
does not consider cases retrospectively
In the sense that the state,
since the ratification
and signing of the Rome Charter,
only issues related to it
are considered,
and claims before that are not considered
Of course, we thought of going to
the International Criminal Court
and it was obligatory to go to do so;
however,
but unfortunately,
no one cared about the issue,
and no one offered a helping hand
No one has asked for a single document yet
Unfortunately, the Journalists Syndicate
has not yet asked us
for a single document
on the subject,
despite their knowledge that the file
has been closed more than once
We are prosecuting the occupation based on
the crime committed
against Palestinian journalists
Also, what is the fate of those
whose names we did not raise, for example
Nazih Darwazeh, for instance,
was before 2014, as we mentioned earlier
Fadel Shana
Between 2014 and 2023,
people whose names have not been included
But the principle
on which we want to prosecute them
is the principle of crimes against
Palestinian journalists,
and international law describes them
as war crimes
Now, almost a year has passed since
the assassination of Shireen
What did the International Criminal Court do?
We notice that there is
delay and sluggishness,
we want to know if the reason is political,
but we should put pressure
Obviously, the International Criminal
Court Prosecutor,
Mr Karim Khan or Mr KK,
since he took over this
about two years ago
and became the ICC Prosecutor.
Clearly, he fully practices politicization
and selectivity
when dealing with the Palestinian file
I mean,
he activated the Ukraine file,
and caused a lot of fuss
Within one year,
an arrest warrant
had been issued
against Putin,
and dozens
of sanctions had been issued
against the Russian Federation,
six waves
of successive sanctions.
Yet, on the Palestinian issue,
he did not move a single millimetre,
even at the level of
contact and communication
with lawyers or with the victims
or visiting areas
Or even give a single statement
about what is happening in the
occupied territories of war crimes
and crimes against humanity
We contacted the Office of the Prosecutor
of the International Criminal Court,
Karim Khan,
for an interview about
the developments of the submitted complaint
and the fate of the cases of
targeting Palestinian journalists
by the Israeli occupation army
We received a response
that the Public Prosecutor
will not be able to conduct this interview
I fear
that one day
there will be pressure
from the politicians,
and they withdraw the case,
as happened with other cases
That is why they keep us
from details
of what is happening
in this case.
However, Mr Nasser, there is
a fear on the part of the victims
or some victims that political pressures
will affect
the future and the outcome
of this legal course
in the International Criminal Court
First: We are an independent Syndicate
representing Palestinian journalists
and their rights
Then we prepared this for
all the martyrs and the wounded;
therefore, this cannot happen,
but we are also
partners with the
International Federation of Journalists
Even if pressures were exerted
on the Palestinian Authority?
This is not our business!
I believe that the position
of the authority is clear
I am not a spokesperson for the authority,
but I tell you clearly that
the statements of the Palestinian leadership,
headed by President Abu Mazen,
call for going to
the International Criminal Court,
and I believe that in recent days
they have submitted files
or will submit other files
against the occupation.
Therefore, this issue of the criminal court
is a process that has begun
and has not yet stopped
After Israel evaded many cases
by killing journalists,
we noticed an approach
towards the International Criminal Court
for the sake of justice
Do you think this road
will be smooth,
or will
Israel also seek
to evade it,
and international circumstances
will help it in that?
I'm not sure if it will work
But, still, I think
this should be the next step
to refer all the murders
to the International Criminal Court
to be reviewed
because in all the lawsuits
that I reviewed,
I still see it looks like
an unfinished novel
So, I would like to see the next step
I would like to see all these lawsuits
being reinvestigated
and a final solution
and conclusion reached
We think about the file every day,
Fadel
Fadel's file is a file
that we, as a family,
have not forgotten
The file is still on the table,
and the file is still open,
awaiting justice
As for me, I have no problem
going to any court in the world
to prove my father's right to this crime,
as he was assassinated in cold blood,
and to protect
the young journalists in the field
From the first moment,
I considered submitting this file
to the International Criminal Court,
not just today
However, the inaction
that occurred in the past period
prevented us from submitting
the file to
the International Criminal Court
because this file was not embraced
even by the former unions
and trade union councils
No one knocked on our door, asking us
to submit the file legally
Obstacles through which
we can
feel that Yasser's case is not
ongoing
It is not justifying the occupation
for sniping,
targeting, or killing Yasser
or the journalists after him
They always try to evade the situation
and justify the Israeli narrative
Then he tries to show that you're an abuser
when you're really only fighting
with your camera
After the injury,
my life turned around
360 degrees
I became like
an old man in his 90s
who only had a few things left
to do before he died
Or as a young child
who would like to live happily
so that he
can enjoy life.
I try to forget as much as I can
what happened to me
so that I do not live
with the burden of the bullet in my head
that could, at any moment,
move
or
cause me major problems
that make me lose the ability
to deal with the people around me
If I can deal with the people around me,
why not?
I try to enjoy as much as I can
until Allah chooses something better for us
In the story of Shireen,
the martyr and witness,
and dozens of companions on the path
who preceded her,
a test of justice
in the face of an occupation that is not
satisfied with killing journalists in the field
but instead seeks to destroy evidence
and block the way for trials
and impunity
in a world of double standards
and it is only the Tip of the Iceberg